on a aussi une autre vidéo regardez
celle ci elle n'était pas pour vous mais
pour m pokora moi c'est angers 13 ans et
je suis fan de m pokora depuis je suis
tout petit
et pour noël j'aimerais vraiment que tu
réalises un de mes souhaits qui dort
montrer mpokora et d'aller à son concert
donc si tu le fais franchement je serai
la plus heureuse et j'espère vraiment tu
vas le faire s'il te plaît baba pour moi
à fait le cas présent est en quatrième
elle vit à aubigny à côté d'amiens et
son rêve c'était de rencontrer m pokora
les équipes ont réussi on a réussi donc
à organiser une rencontre avec son
artiste préféré elle était prête à à le
voir il était prêt aussi à te rencontrer
le problème c'est que avec baba noël
rien ne se passe comme prévu
regardez tout s'est pas passé comme
prévu
bernard montiel était notre complice sur
cette régalade merci bernard est arrivé
sur le lieu du concert à bien vous avez
fait vivre une belle race rare vous a
fait vivre une belle attaque les deux
parce que vous aussi vous n'étiez pas au
courant je sais que tu as reçu un
message très émouvant d'aurélie et ambre
ambre rêve de rencontrer matt pokora
allons nous semble ici à amiens pour que
cette rencontre puisse se faire
alors on a reçu votre message baba noël
évidemment été très touché par ce joli
message
mais dis moi si tu rencontres bat vous
convaincu appâter vanille rien tu vas
pas crier c'est bien écoute on va
essayer de rencontrer pour toi voilà
c'est le cadeau de baba noël ok ok
aurélie allez on y va donner avec moi
[Musique]
sont réalisés on est à quelques secondes
de l'arrivée demain au courant comment
tu lis à bages super contente parce que
ça fait des années que j'ai envie de le
voir
et j'arrive même pas réalisé voilà j'ai
trop est alors envoyé votre fille est là
vous êtes contente de l'avoir amené ici
et c'est un rêve
qui devient réalité c'est bientôt noël
c'est un vrai cadeau noël pour le couple
depuis tout petit en moins c'est vrai
rêve de le rencontrer donc c'est moi je
suis aux anges
voilà donc c'est formidable et puis je
crois aussi je crois un ccao manning me
sens tu veux toujours me sentais quelque
chose avec lui en plus bas j'aimerais
bien c'est génial juste d'accord ok
bougeait pas
c'est rien ça c'est la technique savez
la télé un c'est compliqué j'espère qu'à
pâques est la chasse qui sait
[Musique]
ça fait pas bien présent mais peut-être
un imprévu je sais
ces revers dans la même merde oui mais
non non c'est l'essai c'est pas bien
qu'est-ce que je peux faire moi
bon alors je t'explique
tu sais le business c'est quelque chose
très difficile ma taille beaucoup tu le
sais il est bloqué c'est ce que les
amautas sages en ce moment il est bloqué
chez c est bon mais ça paie j'ai bloqué
a été envoyé quand même un petit message
c'est tellement désolée je suis né
mortiers je comprends c'est matt écoute
cette vidéo pour te dire que je suis je
suis désolé je devais de rencontrer
aujourd'hui malheureusement avec tous
les problèmes sur la route là on est
conscient des bousman d'arriver un peu
trop tard et voilà j'espère qu'on va
pouvoir remettre ça habille toi ça ouais
c'est mignon la vidéo je te laisse
évidemment où la laisserai vidéo madame
je suis vraiment désolé mais non mais
ces choses qui arrivent bon c'est la
séquence il faut quand même le faire
c'est une émission qui passait là c'est
notre chaîne pour battre à noël comme
vous le savez on peut faire des montages
seul est arrivé la semaine dernière avec
garou par exemple en faire brutalement
mais un truc vert et on met la tête de
matt pokora
non mais t'inquiète pas tu regardes et
tu as vraiment parler à quelqu'un on a
eu peur de ce problème depuis ce matin
parce qu'on savait qu'il était bloqué
dans un embouteillage donc on a fait
appel à
sony alors tu essaies de d'imaginer que
c'est matt et tu lui parles comme si c
est mat tu veux bien tenté le coup ah
ouais ça va bien se passer
qui a belle voilà de rentrée bonjour
bonjour voila on arrête on converse
n'était pas attendre tu sais quoi ma
chérie essaie d'imaginer que je suis
vraiment désolé depuis trois jours je
sais mais bon ma chérie alors il ya une
première question
alors quelle impression ça te fait de
voir matt comme ça près de toi bats je
suis trop contente
qui se réalise franchement je suis très
heureuse est-ce que tu le trouve plus
beau qu'à la télé ou sur des posters que
tu attends ta chambre
bah oui un vrai basse c'est pas la même
chose que les photos enfin c'est super
parce que c'est vraiment le plus beau
jour de ta vie oui bah oui voilà il est
là près de toi après pas envie de lui
dire je t'adore jeter suffit défilent
boutin quand même merci et
je suis supporter de voir en vrai mais
moi si ça fait plaisir ça fait toujours
plaisir de voir des fans bien mais qui
nous suivent partout comme ça alors
aurélie ça vous fait aussi de vous
retrouver dans la même pièce que l'idole
de votre film est bien
c'est étonnant oui oui c'est une
surprise étonnante donc ravis et à la
fois
et à la fois effectivement je vais au
met à me remettre de mes émotions là
parce que quand même un petit décalage
quand même effectivement ce qu'on voit
sur les affiches matin beaucoup sur les
affiches de ma fille c'est vrai de vous
voir là avec mousse et ptc un immense
cadeau mer celtique vraiment très gentil
mais c'est devenu très d'offrir sa magie
est alors battre il ya un truc qu'elle
aimerait faire avec toi c'est chanter
une chanson d'accord la champion de toi
c'est quoi ta chanson c'est là que tu
préfères le plus les planètes les
planètes fraises puis trois selles dans
ce cas fin du match par les flashs 216
chambres d'hôtel je te rappelle michel
desroches pas sur la route entre mes
frères et mes doutes
au milieu de la piste dans ce dernier
verre et je pense à toi quand je danse
quand tu danses l'iplanète note aux
totaux
oh oui mais non attendez vont allumer
une panne c'est pas grave ça va et après
ça on va reprendre juste après notre
entretien il n'ya pas troubles là je
suis désolé les enfants c'est vraiment
[Musique]
je vais faire les attendent et on va
reprendre tranquillement les enfants et
moi imaginant ma chérie vraiment tu as
matt pokora tout et voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour
tous
[Rires]
rené maman vous étiez pas bien
[Musique]
ça c'était gênant été arrêtés décennies
rentrée et tout alors voilà alors
regarde cela de vrai c'est énorme c'est
ton cadeau de noël voit du coup les
petits mythe que tout à leur égard des
profiteuses en bois si tu veux chanter
un petit bout avec lui si tu veux c'est
être au vert je sentais le plein tube
c'était son rêve mal ok avec toi aller
quand je danse quand dieu dans les plats
tout autour de moi la différence
je reviendrai ou le v du jour c'est ta
pauvre emma pooley travaux contre ma
peau laisse ta peau contre ma peau
journée
et question mais là il ya plus beau en
rit encore nous jetons quand tu danses
[Musique]
m
d'autres
merci cyril pour tout ce que vous avez
fait parce que c'est aujourd'hui c'est
le rêve de ma fille qui se réalise donc
un gros bisou à toute l'équipe et
1000mercis est joyeux noël
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour moi c'était très drôle et sans trop
bien marché et magnifique est bon très
contente on n'a pas eu peur
oui mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette
arnaque encore de beau dommage c'est ça
on échoue freiner facile et ta maman
était formidable voyez mais gentiment
c'est ma mère qui sait si vous vous êtes
énervé mais ça va trop qu'il soit vrai
merci en tout cas d'introduction les
joyeux noël à vous au plus tard merci
merci
ces magnifiques chiots et bravo à
bernard montiel
[Applaudissements]